-Kesha, come on up here.
-Whoo, Kesha!
-Pull the mic and see what
challenge you'll be getting.
Good luck.
♪♪
Musical Genre Challenge.
Okay.
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge ♪
-Here's how this works, okay?
You're going to get a song title
and a totally different
musical genre,
then you have to sing
that song in that style.
Let's see what you get.
♪♪
"Umbrella" by Rihanna
and Glam Rock.
-Oh, you got this.
-Okay, I can do this.
-All right. Jam band.
-I'm just gonna go.
-Let's go, Kesha.
-Glam Rock.
"Umbrella" in Glam Rock.
-♪ Yow! ♪
-Yeah!
-♪ Well, you have my heart ♪
♪ We'll never be worlds apart ♪
-Sing it, girl!
-♪ Maybe in the magazines ♪
-Yes!
-♪ But you'll still be my star ♪
♪♪
♪ 'Cause in the dark ♪
♪ You can't see shiny cars ♪
♪ And that's why
you need me there ♪
♪ With you,
I'll always share ♪
♪ Oh, 'cause when the sun
shines, we'll shine together ♪
-Kesha!
-♪ Told you
I'll be here forever ♪
♪ Said I'll always be
your friend ♪
♪ Took an oath,
gonna stick it out to the end ♪
♪ Now that it's raining
more than ever ♪
♪ Know that we'll still have
each other ♪
♪ You can stand under
my umbrella ♪
♪ You can stand
under my umbrella ♪
♪ Ella, ella, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Under my umbrella, ella, ella,
hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, under my umbrella ♪
♪ Yow! ♪
-Come on, now!
-♪ Ow! ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-Oh!
-Wow! Just like that.
Just like that.
Come on.
♪ Ella, ella ♪
♪ Hey, hey ♪
-Oh!
-We got more performances
coming.